Hallo, das ist Chaosradio 270. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich spreche in Mikrofone und versuche diese Sendung so ein bisschen beisammenzuhalten. Und ich habe heute nur noch eine Nachricht für euch und die ist lasst uns nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. So enden die meisten Chaosradios. Und heute wollen wir uns mal damit beschäftigen, was das eigentlich genau bedeutet, wenn ich sage, verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups. Gerade im letzten, wollen wir uns ganz ausführlich, wird man also, was ist eigentlich ein Backup? Und das ist so ein bisschen A, sagen wir es die ganze Zeit, es ist immer ein Ruf und B, ist es dem einen oder anderen vielleicht schon mal als Spruch begegnet, da draußen in diesem bösen Internet, kein Backups, kein Mitleid. Und das natürlich ein bisschen doof, aber trotzdem ist das ja so eine Sache, die man vielleicht so vor sich her schiebt, wie Hausaufgaben machen, Abwasch, die kaputten Socken aussortieren, einen Backup anlegen. Ist eine gute Idee, sollte man mal machen. So heute klären wir schon mal, was man machen muss, dann habt ihr das nicht mehr als Ausrede. Ich muss mich erstmal informieren. Und das besprechen wir also heute mal ganz ausführlich von vorne bis hinten. Und dazu begrüße ich recht herzlich Klara. Hallo und guten Tag. So, aus verschiedenen Sparten sind die Menschen heute hier. Klara, du bist IT-Forensikerin. Wenn ich das richtig verstehe, bist du vor allen Dingen an Backups interessiert, weil du dann rausfinden kannst, was die Daten sind, die du brauchst?
Ich habe einen NAS, auf das keine Backup, sondern so eine Spiegelung gemacht wird. Und an dem Ding hängt aber eine USB-Festplatte. Und die mache ich nach meinem Kalender an. Und wenn die angemacht wird, macht das NAS automatisch ein komplettes Backup, aber als Archiv. Also nicht löscht komplett, sondern hat eine Versionierung. Und wenn das fertig ist, kriege ich eine Mail und dann mache ich die wieder von Hand aus. Also da ist so ein Klick-Klack-Schalter richtig an der Steckdose. Aber ich habe keinen Offside-Backup.
Ich wollte ganz kurz Florian eigentlich noch zu Ende bringen. Ich habe nicht keinen Backup, aber tatsächlich mein Backup ist ein NAS, das hinter mir steht, auf dem Tisch, ich befürchte, man hört es auch im Hintergurt, ein bisschen Rauschen im Lüfter. Das macht lokalen Backup mit einer Software, die halt auch immer die Unterschiede sichert, dass ich eine Historie habe. Aber was mir halt auch tatsächlich fehlt, ist dieses Offside-Backup. Und da arbeite ich halt gerade dran. Aber andere Sachen waren aktuell wichtiger. Aber das ist halt genau dieses. Du willst halt irgendwie die super sichere Lösung, dann machst du es halt nicht.
Mein Backup-Verhalten hat sich auch stark verbessert, seitdem ich mal etwas Daten verloren habe. Zum Glück nicht so viel. Das war genau der Moment, wo ich über meine mittelmäßigen Backups sehr erfreut war, weil die mich letztendlich ziemlich gerettet haben. Und ich hatte ein forensisches Labor und forensische Skills, um möglichst die Daten wiederherzustellen. Aber auch das macht gar nicht mal so viel Spaß. Ja, also kommt drauf an. In meinem Fall geht das ganz gut.
Ich hab drauf gewartet, ja.
Wie bei den Juristinnen. Es kommt darauf an. Als nächstes sagt ihr noch vor Cloud oder auf hoher See. Wir sind alle in Gottes Hand.
So ungefähr. Also es gibt halt zwei Anekdoten hab ich halt noch. Das eine war irgendwie von wegen Raid ist kein Backup. Ich hab früher damals, vor vielen vielen Jahren, da war ich noch ganz jung und unerfahren oder so, hatte ich drei externe USB Festplatten an meinem Router und hab dann Raid 5 drauf gemacht. Und dann ist eine vom Bus geflohen. Also Raid 5 heißt, ich habe, also Raid ist ein, wie war das? Redundant Array of Inexpensive Disks, also ein, ich nehme mehrere Festplatten, die vielleicht günstiger sind und packe sie zusammen und sorge dafür, dass Datenredundant gespeichert sind mehr oder weniger, wenn ich jetzt von Raid 5 spreche. Das heißt, eine von den drei Festplatten darf ausfallen und die Daten sind immer noch da, weil mir zwei von drei Festplatten reichen, um sie wieder zurückzurechnen. Und nun war es aber so, dass dieser Controller oder dieses Linux da drauf irgendwie mit dem USB-Bus unzufrieden war und die Festplatte, die weggefallen war und wieder kam, war angeblich die älteste und er hat dann in der falschen Richtung die Daten wieder hergestellt von diesen drei Festplatten. Und ich hatte also auf der Festplatte oder im Dateisystem, ich habe es dann wieder gemountet und sah dann während des Betriebs wie Verzeichnisse verschwanden und plötzlich Sonderzeichen in Dateinnahmen auftauchten. Ich habe es dann ausgemacht, komplett und wieder angemacht und hatte dann alle 64 Kilobyte in allen Dateien Nullen. So über ein Viertel der Dateien. Und habe das dann also über mehrere Wochen quasi forensisch, hobbymäßig wieder hergestellt. Und es macht total Spaß, wenn du Dateien nur noch anhand des Inhaltes, des Dateityps hast, aber keine Namen mehr und dann da 10.000 PNG-Dateien mit Fotos findest und feststellst, oh, das sind alles die Avatare von den Leuten im Moodle-Forum aus der Uni, die da im Forum was geschrieben haben. Und du halt wirklich raten musst, was ist das für eine Datei, wo die gehört sind. Ich hab heute noch MP3-Dateien, mittendrin aber zu, ich weiß nicht, was Merkel Jackson angeht, weil die hintere Hälfte von der MP3-Datei ist aus dem anderen Pfeil. Da hätte ich mir ein gutes Backup auch gewünscht.
Aber Klara, weil du es gerade erzählt hast, oder vielleicht können wir das noch mal so fragen. Du als Profi hast also die Möglichkeiten, da Dinge zu retten. Wie ist denn das, wenn ich, man kann es immer durchspielen, was ist, wenn ich aus Versehen eine Datei gelöscht habe? Könntest du die wieder hinkriegen?
Was hast du mit der gemacht? Hast du sie in den Papierkorb bezogen?
Und dann natürlich, wie ich das gelernt habe, den Papierkorb gelöscht?
Also generell ist es so, natürlich, es kommt drauf an, nämlich auf dem Betriebssystem und Dateisystem, unter anderem in der, bei vielen ist es so, dass du so eine Art Inhaltsverzeichnis hast. Master File Table, zum Beispiel bei NTFS. Und da ist es so, wenn du einen Teil löscht, dann wird erstmal einfach der Eintrag markiert und wird gesagt, na die Datei ist gelöscht und dann kann, na die Datei ist gelöscht und der Speicher an der Stelle kann neu überschrieben werden, wenn das halt gebraucht wird. Kann man sich so ein bisschen vorstellen, wie ein Inhaltsverzeichnis beim Buch und wenn man irgendwas nicht mehr braucht, dann schreibt man einfach eine Notizen oder das kann man neu beschreiben, das braucht man jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr.
Aber die eigentlichen Seiten im Buch sind noch da?
Die sind noch da, genau. Das ist jetzt, da steht auch, wo du nachgucken musst und wie groß es ist im Zweifel und das ist dann relativ einfach, denn guckst du in dieses Inhaltsverzeichnis, siehst, ah, da ist meine Datei, holst der DB raus, ist alles gut, wenn du eine Festplatte hast.
Weil, stopp, stopp, stopp, halt, ich dachte, du hast es gerade so erklärt, wenn ich lösche, wird aus dem Inhaltsverzeichnis rausgelöscht, aber nicht mal das?
Nee, das wird erstmal nur markiert, als, guck mal, hier die Datei ist gelöscht und wenn dann halt wieder Platz gebraucht wird, dann wird das irgendwann neu beschrieben. Wenn du eine SSD hast, dann sieht das wieder anders aus, weil dann, wie wir vorhin schon gesagt haben, bei einer SSD, ja, man kann die nur endlich häufig beschreiben, aber was auch die Sache ist, SSDs können keine Daten überschreiben, anders als Festplatten. Also wenn du eine Speicherzelle neu benutzen willst, dann muss die erstmal gelöscht werden und dann wird die irgendwann neu beschrieben. Also löschen ist im Vergleich zum Schreiben und zum Lesen relativ langsam, deswegen will die SSD schlau sein und macht das so, dass sie immer schon mal proaktiv Speicher freigibt. Das macht sie über unter anderem, also eine Garbage Collection und damit die SSD auch weiß, was kann jetzt eigentlich gelöscht werden, gibt es das sogenannte Trim Command, wo praktisch das Betriebssystem der SSD sagt, guck mal hier, das brauchen wir jetzt gar nicht mehr. Die SSD macht super viel Arbeit selbst und kopiert die Daten in der Gegend rum, organisiert das neu, mappt Daten um, das heißt, was sie eigentlich gerade macht und was da ist, das ist immer so ein bisschen Black Box. Sie versucht auf jeden Fall, schlau zu sein, was dann halt mehr oder weniger praktisch sein kann. Das heißt, bei einer SSD sind die Daten im Zweifel dann auch schneller mal weg. Das heißt, schon gelöscht.
Das führt uns ein bisschen weg vom Thema, aber weil wir gerade dabei sind. Also wenn sie gelöscht sind, gibt es die schon... Ach, da hab ich noch eine Nachfrage. Also du als Profi kannst das. Es gibt ja auch so Programme, die das versprechen. Hier, Sie haben aus Versehen Ihre SD-Karte gelöscht, laden Sie diese Programme für 60 Euro runter. Funktioniert das oder ist das nur... Also jetzt nicht einen bestimmten Typ sagen und ob das gut ist oder nicht. Also generell gibt es so eine Programme tatsächlich oder ist das alles nur Fake?
Nee, die Programme gibt es. Es gibt ja auch, es gibt jede Menge Datenrettungssoftware, die in der Regel auch ganz gut funktioniert. Kann man auf jeden Fall machen. Das eine, den ich jetzt genannt habe, das war der leichtere. Wenn praktisch dieser Eintrag im Inhaltsverzeichnis weg ist, dann hat man auch immer noch Chancen und kann das machen, was eben schon mal erwähnt wurde, dass man nämlich guckt nach den Dateien, praktisch welche Datei-Header findet man. Also Header ist pro Datei Typ, haben viele eine bestimmte Signatur, die den Anfang signalisiert, wo du halt wirklich auf die Bits, auf die Platte direkt guckst und eben guckst, was findest du und was kannst du dann noch an den Teilen wiederfinden. Da gibt es Datenrettungssoftware, die das macht. Es gibt auch Forensiksoftware, die kostenlos ist, die man sich runterladen kann. Das kann man auf jeden Fall mal versuchen, wenn man es tut, ist es auf jeden Fall immer eine gute Idee. Nicht, wenn man das Teil gelöscht hat, erstmal verschiedene Software runterzuladen, zu installieren und dann zu versuchen, das wieder herzustellen. Im Zweifel wird es dann auch schon überschrieben.
Durch die runtergeladene Software.
Es gibt da durchaus Live-CDs, also irgendwelche Linux Live-CDs, die dann von der CD direkt booten. Und ganz wichtig, wenn man irgend so was macht, nie auf den Live-Daten direkt arbeiten. Idealerweise hat man irgendwie eine 1-zu-1-Kopie von der SD-Karte vorher gezogen. In dem Fall der SD-Karte halt. Und arbeitet nicht wieder auf dieser SD-Karte beim Wiederherstellen, sondern auf irgendwas anderem.
Aber wie macht man das denn?
Da gibt es ja auch Software für, die dann einfach eine 1-zu-1-Kopie macht von der SD-Karte.
Das ist vielleicht nicht allen höherer innen, klar. Aber was du meinst, ist ja was anderes, als ich kopiere alle Dateien rüber. Weil dann will ich ja eine Kopie machen, die auch die gelöschten Dateien in Anführungszeichen rüber kopiert. Und das ist dann, wie nennt man das, Bitlevel-Kopie?
Ja, Image. Du ziehst halt eine Image von der gesamten Platte oder SD-Karte. Ein Stichwort dafür ist dann, wenn es um eine kaputte Festplatte geht, zum Beispiel DD Rescue. Das spricht zum Beispiel bei Fehlern nicht ab, sondern versucht einfach dann, den nächsten Sektor zu lesen. Auf diesen CDs meistens ist da auch irgendwas drauf.
Da kopiert man nicht Dateien rüber, sondern man kann sich das vorstellen, wie da wird stumpf jedes Bit von links nach rechts geschoben.
Alles, was lest, wird gelesen, wo extern abgespeichert. Sonst passiert dir halt das, was mir passiert ist. Du hast wirklich viele Geschichten. Ich hab für einen Schulfreund damals noch vom Abi irgendwie, das war irrsinnig teuer, eine 10 Gigabyte Festplatte hatte er, wo ganz viele Daten drauf waren. Da hab ich dann mit Taschenrechner und Hexeditor seinen FAT-Eintrag und sein Dateisystem neu geschrieben, damit das wieder lesbar war. Dann wollte er Windows neu installiert haben und dieses Windows hat dann bei der Installation die Festplatten durcheinander gewürfelt. Und das alles, was gerade refresh restauriert war, formatiert und überschrieben, das war dann unwiederbringlich weg. Weil am Anfang war wirklich nur das Inhaltsverzeichnis weg, das hab ich halt neu geschrieben. Aber ich konnte ihm danach einen Ausdruck über 30 Seiten geben, der mit einer Tiny-Dia verloren hat. Das ist ihm leider auch nicht weiter.
Deswegen, wenn man sowas forensisch macht, kommt natürlich auch hier immer auf die Situation an. Aber wenn man das sauber machen kann, dann baut man die Platte aus, hängt sie an einen Hardware-Write-Blocker, dokumentiert, dass der funktioniert, und kommt dann gar nicht in die Situation, dass man was löscht oder das, was an der Platte geändert wird. Außer natürlich, man hat eine SSD, die, wenn sie angepowered wird, wieder schlau sein will und Daten löscht.
Das Wiederherstellen von Dateien.
Ich glaube, wie man raushört, Forensiker mögen SSDs nicht so gerne.
Kommt so ein bisschen durch. Alex, du wolltest auch mal sagen?
Ja, dieses Daten retten mit Tools. Ich kenne eins, das nennt sich TestDisc. Das funktioniert besonders gut auf z.B. SD-Karten aus Digitalkameras. Weil die haben ein sehr einfaches Dateisystem. Digitalkameras möchten in der Regel auch einfach nur schnell Daten schreiben. Das heißt, wenn da so ein Foto gemacht wird, dann versuchen die das möglichst schnell auf die SD-Karte zu bekommen. Und schreiben in der Regel die Daten eines Fotos am Stück nacheinander hin. Das heißt, man findet, wenn man so ein Image von seiner SD-Karte macht, die Bilder alle schön nacheinander, soweit das geht. Und damit kann man recht viel wiederherstellen. Wenn man also ein Foto gemacht hat von irgendetwas und irgendjemand zwingt einen, das Foto auf der Kamera zu löschen, SD-Karte rausnehmen und zu Hause ganz entspannt ein Image davon machen und da dann das Bild wieder raussuchen. Das klappt ziemlich gut.
Also nicht weiter fotografieren, das habt ihr nicht von uns. Wo wir jetzt aber genau an der Stelle sind. Also ein Backup zu haben ist immer noch besser als zu versuchen, das Video zu recht zu frickeln, aber man kann es versuchen.
Man kann es.
Wenn der Wörskiss eingetreten ist, besteht das Grund zur Annahme, dass es funktionieren könnte. Aber wo wir jetzt gerade dabei sind, gibt es natürlich auch den umgedrehten Fall. Wir entfernen uns ein bisschen, ich kehre gleich zum Backup zurück und zum Fazit dieser Sendung. Wie lösche ich den Daten, das ist jetzt völlig konträr, aber weil wir gerade dabei sind, wie lösche ich den Daten so, dass es eben nicht mehr geht? Vielleicht will ich ja gar nicht. Vielleicht will ich wirklich sicherstellen, dass dieses Bild niemand mehr restaurieren kann.
Na deine Platten sind ja alle schön verschlüsselt. Das heißt, du schmeißt deinen Key weg und dann bist du schon mal nicht so schlecht da. Ich kann aber noch mehr dazu sagen. Man sagt so, wenn deine Verschlüsselung im Boot ist und du den Key wegschmeißt, dann bist du ja safe. Jetzt kann man trotzdem sagen, okay, vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht hast du nicht Vertrauen, dass deine Verschlüsselungssoftware in aller Ewigkeit keine signikikante Schwachstelle hat.
Ich rede jetzt auch eher von den Fällen, ich möchte keinen Ahnung, ich will den Rechner verkaufen oder die SD-Karte, meine Frau braucht eine SD-Karte. Ich formatiere die und frage mich, reicht das?
Wie gesagt, wenn sie verschlüsselt war, ist das schon mal ein guter Anfang. Ansonsten, es gibt, also es reicht nicht, es reicht nicht, weil bei der Formatierung bleiben, also ja, den Video formatierst, aber bleiben Daten erhalten. Es gibt ganz viel Diskussion und sich immer ändernde Hinweise drüber, was man denn dann machen soll, wie häufig man überschreiben soll und mit was. Momentan ist der Ratschlag eigentlich, dass im Normalfall einmal mit einem einfachen Muster komplett überschreiben reicht, außer bei SSDs. Ja, bei SSDs hast du das Problem. Die haben zwei Probleme oder zwei tolle Features, die aber in der Hinsicht jetzt nicht helfen. Das eine ist, dass die, wie gesagt, den Speicher ummappen. Das heißt, du sagst oder dein Betriebssystem sagt, der SSD überschreibt mal das hier mit Nullen. Die SSD mappt das Internum und überschreibt dann gar nicht deine Daten, die du wirklich löschen wolltest, sondern irgendwas anderes. Das andere ist, dass SSDs Speicherzellen ausfallen können und durch Abnutzen halten, die häufig noch so einen Speicher vor, praktisch andere Reserve-Speicherzellen und tauschen den dann hin und her, aber das ist gar nicht transparent nach außen. Also in diesem Speicher können noch Daten liegen, auf die man erstmal keinen Zugriff hat.
Ich würde mich da so ein bisschen an den Richtlinien des BSI orientieren. Ich habe das für berufliche Zwecke mal recherchiert. Und bei Festplatten scheint so der Konsens zu sein. Einmal überschreiben ist in Ordnung für aktuelle Festplatten. Bei SSDs wird das im Prinzip empfohlen, der SSD zu sagen, dass sie sich bitte einmal komplett löschen soll. Das gibt einen Feature namens Secure Erase, was wohl ganz gut funktioniert. Und bei SD-Karten und USB-Sticks, wenn du sie nicht verschlüsselt hast, bist du eigentlich so ein bisschen auf dich alleine gestellt, weil die manchmal auch noch mehr Speicher haben, als sie nach außen rausgeben. Und es da eben dieses lösche dich bitte selber Feature nicht gibt in der Regel.
Aber das heißt, wenn man dem Betriebssystem sagt, bitte, also wenn es soweit kommt, dann kann ich dem Betriebssystem nachher sagen, bitte verschlüssel diesen USB-Stick und dann lösche ich ihn. Dann wäre ich ja wieder auf der sicheren Seite.
Wenn du schon einmal die Daten unverschlüsselt dahingeschrieben hast, dann weißt du ja nicht, ob sie wirklich überschrieben wurden.
Du hast ja das Problem, dass alle diese Sachen immer in Blöcken gespeichert werden, sei es ein Festplattensektor oder ein Flashblock. Wir hatten das Stichwort jetzt schon mehrfach so umschrieben, die SSD versucht schlau zu sein und der USB-Stick auch. Das nennt sich Wear Leveling. Weil die Controller, das sind kleine Mikrocontroller da drin, mit eigenem Betriebssystem, versuchen dafür zu sorgen, dass du nicht bestimmte Speicherzellen zu sehr abnutzt und sie kaputt gehen. Wenn sie merken, dass eine davon kurz davor ist, den Geist aufzugeben, mappen sie intern um. Wenn du einen Block mit Nullen brauchst, und da ist schon woanders einer, dann kreist du auf den zu, statt irgendeinen anderen unnötig zu löschen. Du brauchst ja nur einen Block Nullen, wo der liegt, ist egal. Wenn du jetzt Sachen formatierst oder neu verschlüsselst, belegst du nicht unbedingt gesamten Platz auf dem Ding. Es bleibt immer noch was da, wo du nicht reingeschrieben hast, was nicht gelöscht wurde, wo der Controller nur weiß, wenn ich darauf zugreife, dann lief vielleicht nur Nullen, weil das Betriebssystem hat da noch nie was reingeschrieben. Dann braucht es sich auch nichts anderes zu merken, weil das sind der E00. Das heißt, du kannst dir nie sicher sein, dass du wirklich alles überschrieben hast, dass eine Festplatte nicht einen Sektor umgemappt hat und irgendwo vielleicht noch ein paar Kilobyte oder ein paar Byte private Daten oder genau dieses eine Passwort, was niemand wissen soll, nicht irgendwo noch in einem Sektor drin ist. Deswegen ist die Empfehlung, alle Medien von Anfang an nur verschlüsselt zu benutzen.
Das ist aber bei der SD-Karte in der Kamera ein bisschen schwierig.
Da ist es im Prinzip unmöglich. Da kannst du halt nur komplett eins zu eins alles überschreiben, aber damit reduzierst du natürlich die Limitszeit von so einem Ding dramatisch. Aber je nachdem, was dein Angriff ist...
Aber warte mal, du hast doch gerade gesagt, man weiß gar nicht genau, ob da nicht noch extra Speicherplatz ist, das heißt alles überschreiben, ist ja dann auch nicht wirklich safe.
Was ist denn dein Angriff, also das kommt auf dein Angriffsszenario oder auf dein Bedrohungsszenario an. Dein Szenario ist, du möchtest die SD-Karte einem Kumpel weitergeben, damit er die in seiner Kamera benutzt und der soll halt nicht irgendwie die Fotos von dir finden, die da vorher drauf waren. Dann überschreibst du halt alles einmal komplett auf quasi Bittebene. Dann kann man auch dann nicht einfach sowas wieder herstellen. Wenn diese SD-Karte natürlich einem Forensiker in die Hände fällt, der da irgendwie in einem großen Prozess unendlich viel Geld zur Verfügung hat, um das wiederherzustellen, dann baut er eventuell den Chip aus und je nachdem kann man halt vielleicht Sachen noch auslesen.
Also ich halte mal fest, am Ende hilft immer noch der Flammenwerfer.
Genau, der Termit.
Ja, genau, auch bei SSDs, weil es gerade gesagt wurde, das Secure Erase. Ja, also es implementieren viele. Das funktioniert aber auch nicht immer 100%. Also wie diese SSD-Controller funktionieren, was sie machen, das ändert sich einfach sehr, sehr viel zwischen den Generationen, zwischen Herstellern. Und man hat da auch relativ wenig Einblick. Also Secure Erase ist schon mal super. So komplett drauf verlassen, dass dann wirklich alles weg ist von der SSD, kann man aber auch nicht.
Okay, gut, also weder kann man ein perfektes Backup machen, noch kann man das... Das ist, was für ein Irrsinn diese Digitaltechnik ist. Also nachdem wir eine Stunde lang gesprochen haben, dass es eigentlich ganz schwer möglich ist, ein perfektes Backup zu machen und dafür zu sorgen, dass die Daten wirklich da bleiben, wird dann auch noch in den letzten 10 Minuten erklärt. Dass es aber auch nicht so ist, dass man garantieren kann, dass die Daten wirklich verschwinden. Das ist doch vom Teufel gemacht. Ich würde jetzt zum Anschluss der Sendung nochmal tatsächlich, wir machen das sehr selten und vielleicht habt ihr keinen Bock drauf, dann sagt mir das gleich, aber ich würde es gerne versuchen, nochmal vielleicht tatsächlich sowas Konkreteres zu sagen. Und zwar ausgehend davon, liebe Zielgruppe, ich hoffe das passt so, man ist jemand, der technisch so ein bisschen interessiert ist, jetzt nicht irgendwie ein Hardcore Coder oder sowas, ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie, also nicht auf Betriebssystem Ebene sein eigenes Backup Programm schreiben, sondern man ist jemand, der technisch so ein bisschen interessiert, sagt sich, ok, jetzt habe ich die Sendung gehört, jetzt mache ich, in Zukunft mache ich Backups. Wie könnte so ein Setup aussehen, was so eine pragmatische Abwägung ist zwischen, es ist eben nicht nur eine Spiegelung im Cloud-Anbieter, sondern es ist sozusagen etwas, wo man sagen kann, es ist schon ok, wenn du es so machst. Also liebe Leute, weiterhin schlechtes Backup ist besser als keins. Aber ihr hier versammelte ExpertInnen, wo sagt ihr denn, was ist denn was, was man mal in Angriff nehmen kann?
Also ich würde sagen, nehmt euch eine Backup-Software. Das kann Rastic sein, das kann Borg-Backup sein, das kann eine andere Software sein. Und fangt einfach erstmal an, im Zweifelsfall, erstmal mit einem lokalen Backup, also auf die gleiche Festplatte. Das ist ganz hilfreich für, ich habe die Datei versehentlich gelöscht und brauche sie schnell wieder. Und dann sucht euch irgendeinen Online-Anbieter oder sowas, wo ihr dann eine zweite Version der Backup-Daten auch nochmal ablegt. Wenn ihr ganz sicher sein wollt, benutzt ihr zwei verschiedene Programme, falls es irgendwelche Schwachstellen oder Bugs in diesen Programmen gibt.
Und bei den Online-Anbietern immer verschütteln?
Ja, das war jetzt meine Voraussetzung schon. Entschuldigung, das habe ich nicht extra dabei gesagt.
Ja, finde ich eine gute Herangehensweise. Ich glaube, was auch noch wichtig ist, dass man sich wirklich überlegt, was sind denn die Dinge, wo es wirklich eine Katastrophe wäre, wenn die weg wären, also sei es die Abschlussarbeit oder die Baby-Fotos von den Kindern. Also ich habe mich überlegt, was sind denn wirklich die Daten, die man unbedingt braucht. Die kann man sich im Zweifel auch irgendwie in die Dropbox legen, wenn die super vertraulich sind oder man schickt sie sich selbst in der E-Mail oder man schickt sie irgendjemanden, den man kennt, von mir aus in WhatsApp oder irgendwas. Ich glaube, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, wenn man wirklich anfängt. Erstmal gucken, was sind denn wirklich so jetzt die Grundjuwelen, wo es ganz schlimm wäre, wenn die weg wären und einfach mal schnell pragmatisch eine Lösung finden, die irgendwie wegzuspeichern.
Oh Gott, das will die Hölle Fritz zu Chaosradio mit WhatsApp empfohlen, wenn das rauskommt. Hoffentlich hört niemand diese Folge. Nein Leute, nutzt nicht WhatsApp. Das war ein Beispiel dafür, dass ein schlechtes Backup immer noch besser ist als gar keins. Keine Aufforderung, das zu entzellen.
Also wenn du irgendwie liest, ich war so schlaflos, ich hab die ganzen Babyfotos aus dem ersten Jahr verloren und bin für immer traurig, schick die in WhatsApp. Also klar, installiert ihr der Full Signal oder macht sonst irgendwas, aber low level ist eben, nimmt das, was du eh schon nutzt und schickt's einfach.
Alright, Florian?
Ich würde mich dem im Prinzip anschließen, dass du das mit dem Restdick und online hinschieben. Das ist halt super bequem, weil das ist dann automatisch offside. Es ist halt irgendwie sicher, es ist verschlüsselt. Und wenn ich jetzt irgendwie bedenken hab, dass das viele Daten sind und teuer ist und so weiter, würde ich vielleicht mir noch eine Festplatte kaufen, also eine richtige mit rotierendem Rost und Scheiben und so. Und würde halt die Sachen, die diese Kinder vorderst und sowas, was wirklich wichtig und archiv würdig ist, das einmal auf so eine Platte tun und das irgendwo bei einem guten Freund, Eltern, Verwandten, dem auch immer zu sagen, hier legt das mal irgendwo sicher in den Speicher oder irgendwo, wo nichts drankommen kann, dann hab ich die Sachen schon mal sicher archiviert und das Online-Backup ist dann auch nicht so groß. Aber da kann ich halt wirklich die Dateien und die Daten, die ich benutze, halt sichern. Ich brauch ja nicht unbedingt das ganze Betriebssystem auch sichern, aber halt so die Daten, die ich wirklich brauche.
Also, liebe HörerInnen, lieber einfach Backupen oder schlecht Backupen als gar nicht. Lieber manuell als gar nicht. Ab und zu mal nachgucken, das, was ich da backupe, funktioniert das überhaupt? Also mal versuchen, die Dateien aufzurufen. Und was so total fancy, geo-redundantes Offside-Backup klingt, kann eben auch einfach eine verschlüsselte Platte sein, die man irgendwo hinlegt. Florian, Alex und Klara, vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart und so ausführlich Ausruf gegeben habt. Und auch besondere Dank an Florian für die zerreichenden Anekdoten.
Ja bitte gerne. Ich hoffe, ich bin nicht zu sehr ins Wort gefallen. Das ist beim Nicht-Angucken hier immer alles sehr schwierig.
Das wird bald alles wieder besser. Genau. Jetzt bleibt mir tatsächlich an dieser Stelle nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst sie euch überwachen und verschüttelt immer schön eure Backups.